gonorrhea is a sexually transmitted  disease caused by the bacteria known as  nyseria gonry gonorrhea can be  transmitted via unprotected sex with  multiple partners blood transfusion or  even during pregnancy  the symptoms of Gonorrhea involves  abdominal pain discharge from the vagina  and penis painful urination and many  more  now the bacteria for gonorrhea that  means nisaria gonry can evade the immune  system it secretes protein that actually  degrades the antibodies against them  also it can suppress complement system  and suppress the th1 and th2 helper  cells it selectively promotes the  production of th17 cells and it can also  destroy many neutrophils  this bacteria can be detected with the  help of their Martin media as this is a  bacterial disease it can be treated with  proper antibiotics watch full video to  know more